le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
au côté des
Réunionnais ce balader en forêt est un
moyen de se ressourcer tout en admirant
ce que l'on a de plus précieux à la
Réunion la nature la forêt de Bouve
accueille sur son flanc nord le
magnifique site du trou de fer le
département propriétaire de cette forêt
a permis l'élaboration d'un belvedire en
réhabilitant une plateforme en lieu et
place de ancien site d'observation une
vue imprenable s'offre sur le trou de
fer comment a été réalisé cette
plateforme à plus de 300 m de hauteur
quel panorama offre-t-elle on en parle
tout de suite dans lien
social au nord de la forêt de Bouve sur
un chemin de caiboti et de rondin très
typique une forêt primaire se dévoile au
fil de la balade pour arriver sur une
nouvelle plateforme sur plombant le trou
de fer la balade dure entre 1h et 1h dem
les yeux ne cessent de s'arrêter sur une
nature doté d'une verdure riche et
luxuriante et de diverses
espèces depuis décembre dernier les
randonneurs peuvent observer de ce
belvedire ce fabuleux site en toute
sécurité sans en effectuer la marche
complète une opération qui a coûté près
de 189000 € et qui a été cofinancée par
l'Europe le parc national et le Conseil
Général bonjour
bonjour
bonjour Daniela Grosset chargé de
mission sur les programmes
d'investissement en forêt nous dévoile
le dérouler et les techniques utilisées
de ce bel
ouvrage le site du trou de fer est situé
dans la forêt de bellouve qui est une
forêt remarquable par la diversité de
ces essences son tout d'endémisme et son
très bon état de conservation les
randonneur peuvent CD au site de Bouve
par un sentier qui prend environ 1
heure3 à partir du git de Bouve
l'aménagement donc de la plateforme
surplombant le site du trou de fer
s'inscrit dans le programme
d'aménagement et d'accueil du public
dans les milieux naturels mené par le
Conseil Général donc la plateforme qui a
été réalisée comprend trois niveaux et
s'étend sur une surface d'environ 55 m²
elle a été réalisée en
métallique les pièces ont été fabriqué
sur mesure en atelier et transporté par
hélicoptère sur le site du
chantier cette réalisation technique a
répondu à toutes les préconisations
notamment en matière de préservation du
patrimoine naturel qui est quand même
exceptionnel aux alentours du
chantier mais également en matière
d'intégration paysagère car
effectivement le chantier est situé en
bord de rempart et donc nécessiter
obligatoirement des travaux
acrobatiques en tout état de cause
l'objectif du département est atteint
avec la qualité de cet ouvrage qui
permet d'offrir au grandhonneur un
panorama grandiose sur le canyon du trou
de fer et sur le bras des cavernes la
plateforme a été conçue pour s'intégrer
dans le milieu naturel vous pourrez le
constater au niveau la transparence de
la barrière au niveau des décroch ch que
nous avons sur la sur la barrière pour
justement éviter les espèces
remarquables juste un point
euh géologique sur la formation de ce
canyon le site du trou de fer est issu
d'une dépression géologique du massif du
python des neiges qui a donc créé ce
canyon de près de 300 m de profondeur
sur lequel s'engoufre des cascades
remarquables nous avons aujourd'hui
rencontré beaucoup de randonneurs sur ce
site qui a été
réouvert fin décembre et qui connaî un
et qui connaît un succès il faut savoir
que la fréquentation du site du trou de
fer atteint environ 35000 visiteurs par
an et le site du trou de fer fait partie
du top 5 des sites les plus visités de
l'île le site est superbe par rapport à
la dernière fois on est venu on voyait
pas grand-chose mais là ils ont tout
bien dégagé et on voit très bien la
cascade excellent du coup on voit
vraiment bien on surplom vraiment bien
le trou de fer et c'est c'est magnifique
quoi on a l'impression vraiment d'être
dans le précipice sur le tout à
l'extrémité avait un plateforme de 2 m à
pe pouit tenir de TR personnes pas plus
là maintenant ce matin j'arrive surprise
une plateformme digne de ce on va dire
c'est
magnifique des randonneurs heureux et
émerveillés de cette réalisation
technique novatrice parfaitement intégré
à cette magnifique forêt la vue reste
accessible à un plus grand nombre même à
des randonneurs moins chevronnés un
bonheur à partager également en
famille le Conseil Général de la Réunion
vous a présenté lien social le Conseil
général au côté des
Réunionnais